Usa el método de completar el cuadrado para encontrar las raíces de la ecuación
cuadrática "y" es igual a 4x cuadrada más 40x más 280.
Y bueno lo primero que me gustaría
preguntarme es ¿Qué es una raíz? y una raíz de una ecuación
cuadrática es aquel valor de "x" que hace que "y" sea igual a 0, por lo tanto lo que tengo que hacer es igualdar esta
ecuación que tengo aquí, a 0 para ver qué valores de "x" o qué valor de x
me dan esta propiedad, es decir son raíces y bueno lo que voy a hacer entonces es igualar a 0 me queda que 0, es
igual a 4x cuadrada más 40x más 280 y si te das cuenta, todo es divisible entre
4, 0, 4, 40 y
280 es difícil entre 4, por lo tanto lo primero que voy a hacer es dividir
todo entre 4 para que me sea mucho más fácil completar el cuadrado perfecto. Entonces este entre 4, este también entre 4,
este también entre 4 y esto también entre 4, 0 entre 4 me da 0, 4 entre 4 se van se cancela y solamente me queda "x" cuadrada
40 entre 4 es muy fácil es 10 por lo tanto me queda 10x
y después me queda
280 entre 4, 28 entre 4 es 7 y  me queda 70 y ya tengo aquí una ecuación
cuadrática, que es mucho más fácil de trabajar para completar el binomio cuadrado perfecto y
precisamente como yo lo que quiero es completar el binomio cuadrado perfecto, entonces voy a dejar aquí un espacio para que yo pueda poner aquí,
el cuadrado del segundo y bueno como ya hemos analizado en varios vídeos, para sacar el segundo
término lo que hay que hacer es dividir el coeficiente que está al lado de la "x" que es 10 entre 2.
Entonces dice, 10 si lo divido entre 2 me da 5
5 si lo elevó al cuadrado, es decir 5 es la mitad de 10, y aquí tengo 2 veces el primero de segundo,
entonces 5 si lo elevó al cuadrado me da 25 y en el momento en el que yo agrego 25 en ese mismo momento,
me tengo que fijar que esto es un trinomio cuadrado perfecto y además que tengo que quitar
25 por que recuerda que si yo agrego 25 de la nada
tengo que restar 25 también de la nada, no puedo dejar un 25 nada más por que sí.
Pero ahora lo que tenemos ya está mucho mejor por que "x" cuadrada más 10x más 25, los primeros 3 términos
del lado derecho de esta ecuación "x" cuadrada más 10x más 25 es un trinomio al cuadrado perfecto, que se puede factorizar,
en un binomio al cuadrado perfecto, en que binomio cuadrado perfecto, pues esto es lo mismo que "x" más 5
elevado al cuadrado. Si te das cuenta que tengo el cuadrado del primero, más 2 veces el primero por el segundo
más el cuadrado del segundo, "x" cuadrada más 10x más 25
y por lo tanto esto lo voy a factorizar como "x" más 5 todo esto elevado al cuadrado y después tengo -25
más 70 -25 más 70, también lo puedo reducir.
Tengo 70 -25 es lo mismo que 70 -20 que es 50 - 5 es 45.
Entonces me queda "x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado y a esto le tengo que sumar 45, más 45
y bueno esto no hay que olvidar que es igual a 0. Lo que queremos es encontrar las raíces
de esta ecuación cuadrática y como lo que yo quiero es despejar a "x" lo que voy a hacer a
continuación es quitar este 45 de aquí y lo voy a pasar de otro lado con signo negativo,
o dicho de otra manera de una manera más formal, lo que voy a hacer es restar 45 de ambos lados de mi ecuación,
por lo tanto voy a poner -45 aquí y -45 del lado izquierdo. Aquí es - 45
y aquí es -45 y voy a hacer las correspondientes operaciones.
0 -45 me quedan -45.
Después me va a quedar -45 es igual a "x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado, "x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado,
y después tengo 45 -45 lo cual se cancela,
esto me da 0 por lo tanto, del lado derecho solamente me queda "x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado.
Y bueno ya que tengo esta igualdad lo que voy a hacer para seguir con la idea de despejar a "x"
es sacar raíz cuadrada de ambos lados de la ecuación, y bueno si te das cuenta aquí tenemos un gran problema
por que el problema es que no hay raíces de números negativos o no hay raíces de los números negativos,
al menos en los reales. Cuando yo me fijo en el plano cartesiano estoy hablando de
r2 es decir de los reales, cruz los reales y por lo tanto raíz de 45 no es un número real.
Recuerda que no existe ningún número que multiplicado por si mismo te de un número negativo en los reales.
Este es un número imaginario y es que al final date cuenta que no existe ninguna "x"
tal que al sumarle 5 y elevarla al cuadrado, me de un número negativo.
No existe ninguna "x" que cumpla esta igualdad que satisfaga
esta ecuación y es que recuerda que la raíz cuadrada de -45
no es un número real, es un número complejo y cuando nosotros nos fijamos
en un problema de este estilo, estamos pensando solamente en los números reales, por lo tanto déjame escribirlo. Raíz de
45 no es un número real, no es un número real es un número complejo, y aunque seguramente me vas a decir ¡Sal!.
Yo he visto los números complejos en algún curso de matemáticas, cuando yo busco raíces necesito que estas raíces
estén en los números reales, por lo tanto no existen raíces reales que cumplan esta ecuación
cuadrática y bueno al final, date cuenta que esta expresión no es nada sencilla de factorizar, y no es nada sencilla de factorizar por que no
existen raíces reales.